d'après élection présidentielle les
élèves ont obtenu de très bons résultats
ce second tour puisque nous sommes dans
la fourchette haute de toutes les
prévisions qui étaient faites depuis
depuis une semaine
nous serons vraisemblablement plus de
plus de 60 plus de 60 députés c'est un
échec
cinglant pour emmanuel macron qui paie
le
cynisme qui était qui était le sien
d'avoir en permanence
instrumentaliser les instrumentaliser
les extrêmes pour ce qui nous concerne
ce qui concerne les républicains nous
avons fait campagne dans l'opposition
nous sommes dans l'opposition et nous
resterons dans l'opposition les choses
sont très claires
ce sera comme nous l'avons toujours fait
une opposition constructive et une vraie
opposition à emmanuel macron qui aura
tout détruit son quinquennat aura été un
échec total
et c'est ce qui amène ce résultat
aujourd'hui
à votre disposition si vous voulez poser
des questions aussi la déclaration vous
suffit
oui pardon
si vous pouvez vous approcher sans
problème micron aussi bon c'est bon
julien n'est ni donc france télévisions
est ce que vous diriez comme d'autres
responsables politiques ce soir que la
france est ingouvernable
écoutez en tout cas nous avons une
assemblée comme nous ne l'avons jamais
eu et encore une fois cette la conduite
du quinquennat par emmanuel macron le
fait qu'il a instrumentalisé les
extrêmes on l'a vu à l'élection
présidentielle il a continué avec les
élections législatives et s'amène ce
résultat est
et encore une fois la balle est dans son
et dans son camp aujourd'hui mais pour
nous il n'y a pas d'ambiguïté
nous sommes dans une opposition
déterminée à emmanuel macron
[Musique]